-You know my next guest
from his breakout role
in "Stranger Things."
Now he's starring
alongside Idris Elba
in the new movie
"Concrete Cowboy,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Here is Caleb McLaughlin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about!
That's my man.
How are you, bud?
-I'm good. How are you doing?
-I'm doing great. Welcome back.
Thank you so much
for doing the show.
I appreciate it.
I want to get into your movie.
I thought it was so good.
And I was looking through
some IMDB stuff.
I was looking through
just Internet stuff,
rumors about you, and I wanted
to ask you this question.
There's a rumor out there
that you're going to
release some music?
-Yeah, yeah, I am.
I'm excited. I'm trying to drop
something this year.
-What is your music like?
What's the album gonna be like?
-Man, I mean,
I've been working with this
producer, Rashad, on music.
He's been helping me cultivate
my sound and what I like.
It's like neo soul, R&B,
a lot of Afrobeats.
It's a whole bunch of stuff,
man.
-That's so exciting.
-You know what's funny?
A lot of people,
when they ask me
do I do music,
they think I'm a rapper.
And I tell them yeah
and then I make up a name.
And I'm like,
"Yeah, my name is Centric."
They're like, "What?
That's crazy."
-Centric?
-But I'm like, "Nah."
Centric, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But it's a total lie.
I'm not a rapper.
I can't rap for my life.
[ Laughter ]
-But why not? Yeah, do it. Yeah.
We had your pal,
Gaten Matarazzo, on the show.
Gosh, was it two days ago?
And I was asking about
"Stranger Things" obviously.
And he said that all he knows
about this season
is that it's the scariest season
by far.
-I mean, he's right.
I feel like every season
gets scarier and more gritty.
-Yeah.
-He's very true, yeah.
-Yeah. But this one picks up.
So, I mean, obviously everyone
is growing up and getting older.
Do you know how
you're gonna handle this?
What age are you
gonna be in this?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I know everyone is like,
"Wow, you look so old
and your voice is deep.
You got a beard."
I'm like, "Yeah, it's just
facial hair. Don't worry.
I've always played young
my whole life.
Like, people don't realize
in Season 1, I played 14.
And I was supposed to play
like an 11-year-old.
So I'm used to it.
-Yeah, and you're 54 years old.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm 54.
-That's the magic, yeah.
I mean, you're still young.
Come on. Are you kidding me?
Alright, so, yeah. So you'll
figure out some way to do it.
I want to talk about your movie
"Concrete Cowboy."
It started streaming last week.
And guess what.
Number-one movie on Netflix.
Not too bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nah, it's not too bad at all.
It's great. Blessings.
-I didn't know anything
about this story,
and I thought
it was fascinating.
It's a real community
in Philadelphia, right?
[ Man whoos ]
-Yep, yep, yep, yep.
[ Laughter ]
-That wasn't even a whoo.
What?
That sounded like an animal.
[ Laughter ]
That sounded like a dog got hit
by a car.
It was like...
[ Yelps ]
[ Laughter ]
Do you guys know about this?
It's the Fletcher Street
Urban Riding Club.
-Yeah, Fletcher Street.
-Yep.
-The Roots know about this.
-Yep. Okay, got you, got you.
-Yeah, they're from Philly.
-I didn't know
anything about it.
-Yeah. Can you set up the movie
for anyone who hasn't seen it?
-Oh, yeah, of course.
Well, as you already know,
it's taking place in Fletcher
Street in North Philadelphia.
It's taking place --
Well, it's seen through the
character, my character, Cole.
And he's sent to live with
his estranged father
in Philadelphia.
In his time down there,
he learns about
the urban cowboy culture.
-Yeah, and it's a real thing.
And it's basically
saying to people,
"Hey, this is
another alternative,
something else you can do.
You can become an equestrian
and learn how to take --
and ride horses,"
and it changed
a lot of people's lives.
-For real. Honestly.
It was a life-changing
experience
working in Philadelphia.
-Yeah. I mean, at the end of
the film -- well, no spoilers.
But, well, too late.
I did it already.
[ Laughter ]
-You did it already.
-I really did it already.
At the end of the film,
you see some real riders
and members of the club
and you go, "Wow, that is a --"
And they talk about
their life experience,
how it changed their life.
And it brings a lot of attention
to this organization,
and they're currently trying to
raise money for it as well.
-Yes. Exactly. Yeah.
They've been there
over 100 years.
A lot of people don't know that.
They think that it's just
a thing that just happened now,
but this is a part of history,
American history.
But if you want to
find out more,
you can look it up online,
thepura.org,
or learn about what's going on
at Fletcher Street right now.
Like, everything that you see
in the movie was there.
Like, all the scenery
and everything.
It was beautiful.
-That's wild.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Caleb McLaughlin and
Idris Elba in "Concrete Cowboy."
Take a look at this.
-I can't --
-You need to take this lead.
Alright? Click it on his halter.
Alright?
Let him know that you're there.
Let him know
that you're running this show.
You understand me, Cole?
Come on. You got this.
♪♪
-Hey. Hey, boy.
[ Horse grunts ]
Okay. It's me, boy.
You good. Hey.
♪♪
[ Horse neighs ]
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, relax.
It's okay. Chill. Chill.
It's okay.
♪♪
[ Horse neighs ]
-Come on, man.
You got this. You got this.
-Alright. Hey, it's me.
It's me, boy.
[ Horse neighs ]
-Yeah!
Caleb McLaughlin, everybody!